this outer in the first place acts only
as an organ in making the inner visible
or in general a being for another for
the inner insofar as it is in the organ
is the activity itself the speaking
mouth the working hand and if you like
the leg two are the organs of
performance and actualization which have
within them the action qua action or the
inner as such but the externality which
the inner obtains through them is the
action as a reality separated from the
individual speech and work our outer
expressions in which the individual no
longer keeps and possesses himself
within himself but lets the inner get
completely outside of him leaving it to
the mercy of something other than
himself for that reason we can say with
equal truth that these expressions
express the inner too much as that they
do so too little too much because the
inner itself breaks out in them and
there remains no antithesis between them
and it they give not merely an
expression of the inner but directly the
inner itself too little because in
speech and action the inner turns itself
into something else thus putting itself
at the mercy of the element of change
which twists the spoken word and the
accomplished act into meaning something
else than they are in and for themselves
as actions of this particular individual
not only do the results of the actions
through this externality of the
influences of others lose the character
of being something constant in face of
other individuality but since in their
relationship to the inner which they
contain that behave as a separated
indifferent externality they can qua
enter through the individual himself be
something other than they appear to be
either the individual intentionally
makes them appear to be other than what
they are in truth or else he is too
clumsy to give him
self the outer aspect he really wanted
and to establish it so firmly that his
work cannot be misconstrued by others
the action that as a completed work has
the double and opposite meaning of being
either the inner individuality and not
its expression or Qui external a reality
free from the inner a reality which is
something quite different from the inner
on account of this ambiguity we must
look around for the inner as it still is
within the individual himself but in a
visible or external shape in the organ
however it is present only as the
immediate actual activity itself which
attains its external ization in the deed
which either does or again does not
represent the inner the organ regarded
in the light of this antithesis does not
therefore provide the expression which
is sought
here in paragraph 312 I think that
you're going to now see some of the
central themes and get a sense for the
you might call it the flavor of this
entire section of the work or at least
the first part of the section because
we're talking in terms now not just of
individuality xand laws and bodies or
even in terms of the inner the outer but
in terms of what we might call concrete
actualization things that we can we can
relate to quite well that's one of the
things that I really like about this
section as opposed to some of the others
that you know it often feels when we're
reading hagel as if we're groping around
a bit trying to fit well what what does
the negativity meet in this case here
we're actually talking about stuff
that's very easy for us to place
oftentimes experiences that we ourselves
have had and can easily recall you can
be talking about hands and mouths
actions speech and about the slippage
that occurs between those and what it is
that they're supposed to be expressing
so he begins by talking about the outer
the outer from the last paragraph as you
know something that's supposed to
express the inner but it acts as an
organ a sense or if you like a tool
right an instrumentality for making the
inner visible and Hagel is going to talk
quite a lot about the visible and the
invisible in paragraphs yet to come
sometimes in paradoxical ways talking
about a visible invisible or things
along those lines so just going to be
attentive to that he says in general of
being for another right it makes the
inner of the the the individual the
human person visible for another not
just for themselves this is not a soul
lips ism with the individual
individuality standing in front of a
mirror this is an individuality existing
with
in a world of other human beings and
we're going to see this this come to the
fore so he says the inner insofar as it
is in the organ is the activity itself
so we have the inner as activity the
inner can be in the organ invisible
within it right and this leads to an
externalization not just an expression
but an externalization he goes on and he
says the speaking mouth the working hand
and if you like the legs to are the
organs of performance and actualization
which have within them the action qua
action what does it mean to be an action
we started exploring this earlier in the
first section of observing reason and an
to lesser extent in the
self-consciousness section now we're
actually grappling with this what does
it mean to be action as action well it
means to be externalized and this leads
to a sort of you can call it a paradox
if you like namely that the action of
the person whose action it is ceases to
be their action alone this is something
by the way that that another great
dialectical philosopher often called the
French Hagel or the Catholic Hagel that
is Maurice blown del devoted an entire
book to analyzing the the dialectic of
action so going on with this he says
these are the organs of performance and
actualization which have within them the
action qui action or the inner as such
they says but the externality which the
inner obtains through them is the action
as a reality separated from the
individual so there's a natural movement
a natural tendency a natural desire to
externalize oneself not just one's
intentions but oneself in expressive
action
action which makes what it is that you
are visible to the outside world but in
doing so the action ceases to be solely
expressive of you why because it is for
another it is gone out into a world that
you don't control how many times have we
seen this sort of thing happen so he
goes on and he says speech and work
great examples our outer expressions in
which the individual no longer keeps and
possesses himself within himself right
that would be to be closed off within
oneself keeping oneself within oneself
if you want to have your being visible
for yourself to know what you are hagel
things that we do you have to
externalize it but in external izing it
you cross over this threshold into the
world of others who can decide what they
want to make of your your speech your
action and generally don't interpret it
in the way that you do which leads to a
lot of disappointment and frustration
and then you know there's there can be a
dialectic well I'm you know withdrawn to
myself screw all the rest of them they
don't understand me but then you want to
express yourself right and so you do
express yourself again perhaps after
more reflection after you know making
sure that they can't possibly
misunderstand you and sure enough they
misunderstand you and miss appropriate
your actions and perhaps even get them
completely wrong and this can go on and
on and on so he goes on and he says here
we go speech and worker outer
expressions they let the inner get
completely outside of him leaving it to
the mercy of something other than
himself now think about that think about
how many times how many ways and in how
many different modes we do something or
we say something
and other people either misinterpret it
or perhaps even perversely twist it
around or they turn it to their own
advantage and make it into something
else that we hadn't intended you know
classic example of this if we want to
think about you know interesting plays
in terms of romance think about Cyrano
de Bergerac you know and the famous help
that he's giving to his friend who's a
bit of a lummox and tongue-tied and
can't actually help himself out with
with a girl that he ought to express his
mind his love for right Cyrano gives him
the external ization the words and when
Cyrano does so those words cease to be
his and at first he's thinking oh this
is great you know I'm perfectly happy to
do this for a friend but then he falls
in love with the girl right and he wants
her to recognize that those words are
not that big ox who's been saying them
but that pointy nose guy who happens to
be one of the greatest swords people in
France and we could say that about
action to think about his is action of
fighting with a sword right that can be
interpreted in all sorts of ways that
can once you you know make a move you've
committed yourself we go on and on and
on about all these sorts of things
that's what makes this so so interesting
I think so he goes on and he says this
is the reason we can say with equal
truth that these expressions express the
inner too much as that they do so too
little they don't express it to the
right amount they express it either too
much or too little so how do they
express it too much in creating a kind
of vulnerability we've all had that
experience when we do something or we
say something that truly does manifest
who we are or at least what we mean to
manifest at that moment
and now we're exposed we're naked we're
open we're out in front of the world you
know think about what goes on with
youtube all the time right people create
videos and then they see the comments
rolling in and some of the comments are
just from trolls who say yo you you suck
you're no good you know and you know if
you if you're not ready for that sort of
thing that can be very devastating some
of the comments will be well I think
you're wrong on this point and or hey
this is so great and then they take
something that you said that one thing
and they run with it and turn it into an
entire paragraph and you're like well
that's not exactly what I meant so hagel
goes on he says too little right because
in speech and action the inner turns
itself into something else less putting
itself at the mercy of the element of
change which twist the spoken word and
the accomplished act into meaning
something else than they are in and for
themselves as actions of this particular
individual oh you know I punched that
guy in the nose well you're such a you
know brave person standing up against
the bully well I didn't mean to stand up
against the bully I just didn't like
that guy your reaction has been
transformed by people adding a narrative
to it by slipping it into a kind of
schema this happens in human
relationships all the time and it
happens in particular when we have
situations in which a lot of different
let's call them schemas or scripts are
already in place these are furnished to
us by the culture part of what it means
to become a mature individual is to
learn how to move around within these
scripts and not be simply held at their
mercy so in a way the expression the
action of the speech expresses too
little it doesn't adequately express
what the individual is trying to
externalize out of their inner out of
there
activity out of their consciousness what
else he says too much right because the
inner itself breaks out in them and
there remains no antithesis between them
and it they give not merely an
expression of the inner but directly the
inner itself this is when you're super
vulnerable right you somebody says oh
you really didn't mean that thing that
you said thank you what a jackass what a
what a naive person oh my goodness you
really meant that are you really
intended to do that stupid action that
idiosyncratic action that whatever it is
we make ourselves vulnerable to other
people who are themselves it gets even
more complicated doing the same thing in
saying anything to us except insofar as
what they're saying is the most
stereotyped and impersonal of things so
too much and too little so he says not
only do the results of the actions
through this externality of the
influence of others lose the character
of being something constant in the face
of other individuality so what we're
trying to do is when we act in a
meaningful way when we say things in a
meaningful way we want them to stand as
sort of a monument or a testament or an
ongoing witness to what it is that we
are expressing but the world of others
is a shifting world you may say
something to this other and then you
find that this other other over here
interprets things completely differently
we've all had the experience of probably
offending somebody in telling a joke
that was originally supposed to you know
make us laugh and then we
find out that it's actually offensive to
somebody else or we can say this about
all sorts of other expressions where we
didn't mean to give offense to that
other person but then afterwards we can
say oh yeah I see how they could take it
that way they can take it with that way
because there are different
individuality right so he goes on and he
says in their relationship to the inner
which they contain that behave as a
separated in different externality they
can't qua enter through the individual
himself be something other than they
appear to be once we let our words and
our actions go out into the world we're
not in control of them anymore we can
try to spin them right we can try to
manage them this is why some people in
their social media keep it super
lockdown they don't want their words
escaping out there into the ether that's
why some people on their YouTube
channels block comments or make sure
that all the comments have to be
regulated they want to keep control over
that I'll admit that I myself do that on
certain videos where I'm discussing very
controversial topics you notice that I'm
not doing that here on the hagel videos
but this is also sort of a risky thing
as well Hagel has externalized his point
of view into this this book the
phenomenology perhaps i'm totally
misinterpreting it that would mean Hagel
in his expression of his inner mind has
gotten screwed over by by me the
interpreter or perhaps my interpretation
reaches you and you say that guy's crazy
this isn't what Hagel saying at all you
know because I read on a website then
what Hagel's really talking about is
thesis antithesis synthesis where when
is he going to get to that stuff right
these are the risks that we take in
existing in a world in which we don't
just exist but we do things and we say
things he goes on he says here we go
either the individual intentionally
makes them appear to be other than what
they are in truth one possibility or he
is too clumsy to give himself the outer
aspect he really wanted and is so
established and to establish it so
firmly as work cannot be misconstrued by
others these are things that we can say
amount of people the action he says then
as a completed work has the double and
opposite meaning of being either the
inner individuality and not its
expression the vulnerability showing
what's what's inside or Co external a
reality free from the inner a reality
which is something quite different from
the inner here is where the possibility
of deception of hypocrisy of literally
putting out a mask comes into play as
well by using stereo typed language we
can try to create and Athos Aristotle
actually talks about this in book three
of his rhetoric the art of rhetoric the
art of finding the means of persuasion
right this is not something radically
new on the scene Descartes also talks
about this quite a bit in the passions
of the soul the fact that the passions
can be counterfeited on the face which
is supposed to be sort of the the screen
on which we see a person's passions so
he says on the action is a double and
opposite meaning on account of this
ambiguity this this ability to be both
ways we must look around for the inner
as it is still within the individual
himself but in a visible or external
shape where are we going to find that in
what we call the organ here in the organ
ESA's however it is present only as the
immediate activity itself the activity
goes into
uses inhabits the organ which attains
its externalization in the deed the
action the twin you know which either
does or again does not represent the
inner so we have this problematic and
you know we might be tempted to say you
know you know where the real problem
lies stupid organ getting in the way if
only we could have some way of going
directly from the inner out into the
world of action everything would be
crystal clear and that's a dream that's
just a an imaginary solution it's not a
real solution to this this fundamental
problem so he says the deed either does
or does not represent the inner the
organ regarded in the light of this
antithesis does not therefore provide
the expression which is sought so what
do we do we are in an area we are in a
problematic that it doesn't seem that we
can get out of perhaps we can try to
specify the relationship between the
activity and the Oregon enter in the
outer or perhaps we can more fully
specify the relation to that which is
outside those are both ways of
approaching this Hagel is going to as
you were to see try a number of
different ways to make sense out of this
relation in the paragraphs to come
if now the outer shape could express the
inner individuality only insofar as that
shape is neither an organ nor in action
hence only insofar as it is a passive
whole it would behave as an existent
thing which passively received the inner
is an alien element into its passive
existence and thereby became a sign of
it an external contingent expression
whose actual aspect lacked any meaning
of its own a language whose sounds and
sound combinations are not the real
thing itself but are linked with it by
sheer Caprice and are contingent in
relation to it
after that long discussion in the last
paragraph we now have a short and and
rather succinct paragraph in 313 there's
really one main idea running through
this or at least say one constellation
of ideas and we're back to thinking
about the relationship between the inner
and the outer and whether expression is
really possible so the inner or the
individuality which is consciousness and
activity is still attempting to express
itself in in the outer so he says if the
outer shape the gestalt could express
the inner individuality only insofar as
that shape is not what we tried to make
it in the last paragraph so that is not
an organ not the action which is an
external ization which makes it a being
for another out there in the world what
is left to us well what is the neuter of
Oregon and action in this case Hagel
says that it is to be a thing he says
it's so far as it is a passive whole it
would behave as an existent thing which
passively received the inner as but as
an alien element into its passive
existence so we're able to have some
sort of not expression but something
going on here sort of like des cartes
metaphor for the body and the soul of
the soul as being like the pilot in the
ship right steering it around it's
really an alien element it's it's for
into it it'll take heart says it's a
different substance right that's sort of
what Hagel's talking about here but
Hagel goes a different way with this
here he says therefore it became a sign
the thing is a sign of the inner of the
individuality that doesn't sound that
bad right we're used
thinking of signs in terms of what we
call in linguistics motivated signs or
there's some sort of connection between
the sign and that of which it is a sign
but Hagel doesn't see it that way if
we're dealing with signs we now venture
into the realm of what he calls language
praha but a particular kind of language
in which the relationship between the
sign the thing that's signifying and the
signified is as he says capricious or
contingent it's not something we can
actually rely upon so for the purposes
of expression this is not going to be
particularly helpful right when we
express something in terms of signs
whether those signs be our words or
actions or something else some visual
medium that we're working with or
perhaps even something just in terms of
computer code whatever it happens to be
right waves of water doing certain
things we want there to be some sort of
connection and not a purely arbitrary
one between the sign and what the sign
is the sign of so he says this is a real
problem we get a language whose sounds
and sound combinations are not the real
thing itself but our link to it in these
arbitrary or contingent ways and so what
is the implication well the implication
is in so far as the outer is going to be
a passive thing we're going to run into
a problem but that's exactly what's
going to happen with these
pseudo-sciences that were ultimately
going to look at
you